three people leading the investigation
join us now joining us now chairman of
the house Judiciary Committee Jim Jordan
chairman of the house government uh
oversight and accountability committee
James comr and the chairman of the house
Ways and Means Committee uh Jason Smith
is with us thank you
all all right Jim Jordan let me start
with
you I keep hearing from the media mob
and Democrats and the White House
but but there's no evidence none at
all uh you have a list of evidence I
think you could probably go on for the
next 10 minutes giving us evidence yeah
I'm going to try to go to the central
evidence I'm going to go to the
transcript that we just had of the
deposition of Hunter Biden's business
partner dein Archer we ask him this
question I got it right here Sean the
request was from the United States
government to deal with the pressure
they were under from their prosecutor
Deon Archer's response to that question
was correct next question what did
Hunter Biden do after he got that
request Deon Archer's answer he called
his dad which begs the real question
what then did Joe Biden do Joe Biden
five days later after this happened on
December 4th 2015 Joe Biden gets on a
plane flies to Ukraine and starts the
process to fire the prosecutor the very
guy they ask him to go after because he
was applying the pressure and they don't
stop their Shan after they get that guy
fired the next proc utor they work on
making sure he drops the charges against
the barisma executives that Hunter Biden
was working for if that's not a corrupt
influence pedaling scheme I don't know
what is and that's exactly what
Professor Turley called it today in our
hearing James comr let's go over the
evidence and there's a lot of it to sum
up the biggest evidence that you in your
committee and you had a great couple of
lines and opening statement today that I
think everybody needs to see uh talking
about the bank records tell everybody
watching right now what evidence do you
have we have Bank wires that show that
Biden took $20 million from foreign
Nationals in at least five different
countries they can't say one thing they
did to earn that $20 million we also
have evidence that they started 20 shell
companies they used these shell
companies to receive the wires from the
foreign Nationals and then according to
the banks in the 170 different
suspicious activity reports those were
the bank violations they then took those
wires through the shell companies and
laundered them down to the Biden family
to nine different Biden family members
in incremental payments that shows money
laundering uh that shows a lot of
problems with respect to influence ping
and it's interesting Sean in your
monologue you showed the clip from Dan
Goldman he admitted that the Biden
family was influenced Pedley and and and
he admitted that Joe Biden lied and he
you know that's was really the basis for
our first hearing to justify why we're
going to impeachment inquiry and to
prove that Joe Biden lied over a dozen
times about his knowledge and
involvement in his family's business
schemes and and to prove that this
family was influence pedaling and I
think every American has a problem with
the fact that our president's family was
selling access to him to our enemies
around the world all right so we have
shell corporations we have 170
suspicious activity reports um and we
have nine family members that you have
identified having been paid and you
believe at the end that this is going to
go north of maybe $50 million for the
Biden's
alone well we've got to get to Jim Biden
and that's why today I signed the
subpoenas to subpoena Jim Biden's
personal bank accounts he's flown under
the radar because quite frankly he
didn't leave a laptop laying around but
uh we know from people we've talked to
uh from evidence in emails and text
messages that he too was just as
involved as Hunter Byron Donald showed
that text message today from Jim Biden
to Hunter Biden when Hunter was going to
rehab again he said don't worry I'll
work with your dad we'll finish those
deals I mean there's overwhelming
evidence that Joe Biden was involved in
all of these Shady business schemes
that's a problem that's a threat to our
national security and today we rehashed
and went over all the different items of
evidence and we announced the subpoenas
we're going to continue to move forward
and follow the money Jason Smith the
house ways a means committee uh you have
an important role in all this
investigation your all of your
investigations seem to run in tandem
what have you learned about Joe Biden
his family uh never mind it all started
with lies and the fact is he met with
and talked to many foreign business
partners and and even had dinner with a
Russian oligarch and other you know
business partners at Cafe Milano doesn't
sound like a guy that never talked to
his son brother or anybody for that
matter about business what have you
learned of the house ways and mean
committee that's exactly right Sean in
fact yesterday the house Ways and Means
Committee released over 700 pages of
documents that we received from the IRS
whistleblowers and in those documents
Sean we we know that that President
Biden was aware of his son's business
dealings but these documents prove that
he was connected to his son's business
dealings through emails through phone
calls through um dinners at the White
House to foreign trips on Air Force 2 we
also know that Hunter Biden and his
associates have business contacts in 23
verified different countries bringing in
more than 20 million dollar which he
didn't pay taxes on a big part of that
amount but we also know Sean that there
was such obstruction that that there was
not only obstruction in investigating
Hunter Biden but there was obstruction
in inv investigating President Joe Biden
there was a count where Joe Biden was
mentioned in a search warrant and the
justice department made his name be
taken out of the search warrant we also
know that the IRS investigators thought
that they should pursue campaign Finance
violations and guess what the justice
department said under no circumstance go
into Joe Biden well last Jim Jordan you
have four that never change what are
they Hunter Biden gets put on the board
of barisma fact number two he's not
qualified to be on the board he said so
himself fact number three barisma
Executives ask him to weigh in and
relieve the pressure fact number four
Joe Biden does just that weighs in
relieves the pressure and that last fact
is entirely consistent with what the
confidential human source told the FBI
and they recorded it in the 1023 form
and then the final fact is the justice
department tried to sweep it under the
rug this Sean this is a tale as Old As
Time politician takes actions that
benefit his family financially and then
they try to conceal it that is as old as
the hills and that is exactly what looks
like played out am I correct in
describing this as the Joe Biden bribery
money laundering Scandal allegations uh
yes or no Jim comr yes Jason yes or no
absolutely Jim Jordan yes or no that
sure looks like what the facts are
pointing to Sean that's why we're doing
this thank you for sharing your time and
your information with the American
people that are being lied to by the
media every single day and by the
Democratic party we appreciate it hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else